it was 1883 when computer programming
started after centuries hundreds of
programming languages have come into
existence in the quest to be the most
agile and powerful enough to dominate
the industry a few impeccable ones
managed to withstand the test of time
and a few seem a lot ahead of time now
the question arises which of these
programming languages are the ones you
should learn so you are already watching
simply learn and today we bring you the
list of the top 10 programming languages
to learn in the year 2023. at number 10
we have rust when the Achilles heel of C
plus plus was revealed many companies
including Dropbox Firefox cloudflare and
many others needed to find a solution to
code safety in 2020 Russ came into the
picture rust is a multi-paradigm general
purpose programming language develop by
Firefox as an operational replacement
for C plus plus but rust was more
capable than just offering memory and
code safety Russ's high performance
compiler makes it ideal for processing
heavy data loads currently meta Amazon
Microsoft and many organizations are
dependent on Rust for several operations
the salary of a rust programmer is nine
lakh rupees in India in the United
States of America the salary is around a
hundred and ten thousand dollars per
annum at nine we have go programming
language also known as golang Google
designed a simple yet statistically
typed programming language that is a
brilliant combination of advanced memory
safety and garbage collection with the
Simplicity of the C language golang was
originally developed to support the
programming for networking and
infrastructure requirements go seemed to
be a viable substitute for high
performance programming languages like
Java currently golang has a wide range
of applications across cloud computing
server-side scripting devops and many
more companies like twitch Uber Dropbox
and Google have adopted the go language
the average salary of a go developer is
135 000 USD and in India the salary of a
go developer is 10 lakh Rupees annum
based on your experience next we have
kotlin many believe kotlin is the future
that surpasses Java peculiarly there's
more Java can do than just develop
Android kotlin just makes things easier
for Android when compared to Java both
these powerful programming languages are
put on head-to-head comparison in
Android
but kotlin is designed based on Java yes
kotlin runs on jvm more on the
differences in our kotlin versus Java
video in the I button above Ming and
many more companies are active users of
kotlin the salary of a kotlin developer
in India is 10 lakh Rupees per annum and
in America the salary is 140 000 per
annum at seven we have SQL structured
query language is one of the most
successful languages and is considered
an important skill for every programmer
lately SQL is a data language that is
used to create data tables it stores
data communicates with the database and
manipulates data to fetch the required
results which is a major part of data
analytics companies like NTT data
Microsoft Accenture and others use SQL
the salary of an SQL Developer in India
is one million one hundred thousand
rupees and one hundred thousand dollars
in the USA at six we have typescript
typescript is Microsoft's yet another
powerful programming language
typescripts share similarities with
JavaScript but follow strict and
tactical practices with brilliant
tooling at any scale
companies like Accenture Microsoft and
more use typescript the salary of
typescript developers in India is two
million two hundred thousand per annum
in America the salary is one hundred and
sixty thousand dollars per annum at five
we have Swift if you want to develop
anything for Apple Swift is your savior
originally Apple used Objective C it was
one of the oldest programming languages
that needed programmers to be well aware
of a large variety of libraries
Objective C was verbose and time
consuming to adapt so Apple develops
Swift and migrated from Objective C
dramatically minimizing the efforts and
time required to develop software and
applications for Apple devices apart
from Apple companies like uber Robinhood
and a few more financial companies are
active users of Swift
Apple software developers are highly
paid Professionals in India Swift
developers are paid 10 lakhs per year
and Swift developers bag about ninety
thousand dollars per annum in America up
ahead we have C and C plus plus the
humble languages of the entire clan of
programming C is titled the mother of
all programming languages the veteran
programming language has contributed a
lot to developing new languages
compilers databases and one of the most
popular operating systems Microsoft
Windows
on the other hand C plus plus is an
advanced version of C with
object-oriented programming abilities C
plus plus is used for web development
games and much more companies like
Microsoft Netflix and many more use
these programming languages the average
salary of C and C plus developers in
India is 10 lakhs per annum in the USA
the salary is one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum next we have
the top three programming languages
you've been waiting for at three we have
JavaScript the most versatile and
Powerful language that turned the face
of the internet JavaScript is a leading
programming language with the highest
number of communities and active users
worldwide an astonishing number of 65
percent of programmers around the world
use JavaScript
sharing the podium are python with 48 in
the second and Java with 33 percent in
the third
JavaScript is used majorly for web
development by companies like Netflix
Google PayPal big basket and more
the salary of a JavaScript developer in
India is one million six hundred
thousand per annum and then the USA the
salary is 135 000 per annum at number
two we have Java
Java is Invincible among all languages
Java has the largest community
repositories and support it has spread
its roots into every software framework
mobile application big data and
operating system you name it Java did it
I.T giants like Ming and many other it
firms use Java the salary of a Java
developer in India is one million two
hundred thousand per annum and in the
USA the salary is 120 000 per annum
finally our number one programming
language is python
many believe that python is one of the
newest programming languages as a matter
of fact it's a veteran programming
language that is a lot older than Java
python was developed keeping one thing
in mind Simplicity python is not verbose
and it comes with the most simplistic
syntax python shares similar credibility
as Java in terms of operations and has
established its firm foot in the field
of data science and data analysis lately
Ming and it giants like Intel Pixar IBM
and more use python python ears earn
handsome salaries the salary of a python
programmer in India is 1 million per
annum and in the USA the salary is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
annum
that concludes our list of top
programming languages for the year 2023
what are you waiting for get started
with your programming Journey with
simply learn where we offer courses for
all the languages discussed links in the
description let us know in the comments
section which one is your favorite
programming language and why the
evolution of programming languages have
paved the way for new possibilities in
the world of software development
believe it or not according to the
historical Encyclopedia of programming
languages we have
8945 programming languages and Counting
it's a natural law that nothing lasts
forever likewise despite their
unparalleled caliber and contribution to
the I.T industry there are a few
languages going obsolete the
introduction of a few rookie programming
languages makes the current ones look
like their Valor is coming to an end
soon now the question arises which of
these programming languages are the ones
you should least focus on
we have created this video based on the
trends potential job opportunities
repositories programmer communities and
surveys on websites like stack Overflow
and many more
so you are already watching simply learn
and today we bring you the list of the
top 10 dying programming languages in
the year 2023
at number 10 we have coffee script
coffeescript is one of the lightest
languages ever designed coffeescript a
single threaded and synchronous
programming language had fewer lines of
code than JavaScript would increase
readability compared to its predecessor
coffeescript was adopted by major
companies like Dropbox GitHub and many
more to develop their browser site code
however the latest migration chose
JavaScript as a better alternative as of
January 2020 coffeescript was declared
Obsolete and is no more operational
at number nine we have Ruby with six
percent of the worldwide programmers
Community Ruby is in ninth place on our
list for today Ruby is extensively used
in building web applications data
processing Automation and many more the
most prominent of all its applications
is Ruby on Rails also known as RoR it's
highly believed that Ruby still has a
lot of potential but it's considered
obsolete based on its competition allies
like python are comparatively less
verbose highly readable and offer better
code security than Ruby hence slowly
Ruby is also becoming obsolete if not
completely dead at number eight we have
VBA Visual Basic VBA was one of the most
extensively used programming languages
not only beginners but also corporates
also use the VBA the language could
build High Performance Tools to extract
data from various sources companies like
Microsoft arcgis AutoCAD core draw and
labor office used VBA to manage their
internal operations
Microsoft's VBA currently shares four
percent of the worldwide developer
Community despite being based on.net it
is no longer updated by Microsoft
indicating its obsolescence
at number seven we have Scala Scala was
a well-known language in the developers
Community for a really long period it is
one of the most powerful languages that
are based on Java with the potential to
process petabytes of Big Data it's not
because of performance but because of
the features which most developers are
unaware of yes migration to Scala from
java is a little difficult as it offers
a steeper learning curve also skull has
a smaller developer community of 2.9
worldwide making support scarce
at number six we have Objective C
Objective C has already established a
firm foot in the world of application
development so much so that libraries it
supports are nearly impossible to
recreate with a new language Objective C
was originally used by Apple to develop
its applications for Apple devices but
due to its verbose nature complex syntax
and outdated libraries Apple made the
switch to Swift for the ease of code
readability and application development
with less than 2.5 percent of the
worldwide developer Community Objective
C is close to becoming an obsolete
programming language soon
number five we have Pearl originally
developed for script manipulation Pearl
has turned out to be one of the go-to
languages for web development it is one
of the most efficient open source
languages for text manipulation despite
its Simplicity and efficiency Pearl
comes with a major drawback Pearl fails
to support portability because of cpan
modules programs run slowly and must be
interpreted each time any changes are
made these drawbacks have resulted in
the drop of developers in Pearl
currently it has less than 2.3 percent
of developers worldwide at number 4 we
have Haskell with similar numbers a 2.2
percent share of developers worldwide we
have Haskell earlier Microsoft and
similar companies depended on Haskell
for their software development lately
Haskell has faced issues like no proper
IDE support complex syntax and a steep
learning curve this forced developers to
migrate to better alternatives
also Haskell's major disadvantage is its
inability to support Android development
these are some of the significant
reasons to turn Haskell into a fading
programming language
now we come to our top three most
powerful yet obsolete languages at
number three we have Fortran
Fortran had laid foundations in various
domains for a decent period of 30 years
everything was handled using Fortran
from designing Bridges to airplanes and
Factory automation to data analysis
such a glorious language also turned
obsolete while facing the test of time
developers soon had to migrate from
Fortran due to a lack of dynamic memory
reliability and unsafe code prone to
cyber threats currently less than one
percent of developers worldwide are
working with Fortran at number two we
have erlang erlang escalated
telecommunications processes to new
heights for Ericsson apart from telecoms
erlang supported banking e-commerce
computer systems development and instant
messaging services
despite its capabilities to develop
almost everything in the tech industry
the Achilles heel of erlang was its
complex debugging procedures and
critical deployment issues this resulted
in the deterioration of the might of
erlang today a handful of developers
with less than one percent worldwide
operate in erlang
that brings us to our top programming
language which is slowly becoming
obsolete at number one we have Cobalt
cobal is one of the languages from
Mainframe computer era the early
Mainframe programming for business
transactions Banking and many more was
handled by COBOL since its veteran
programming language it had a tougher
verbose syntax with slow compilation and
deployment today with less than 0.5
percent of the developer Community COBOL
is considered one of the legendary
programming languages going extinct
that concludes our list of the top 10
dying programming languages for the year
2023. which of these programming
languages are the ones you like the most
and wish they stay for a while in the IT
industry let us know in the comments
section which one is your favorite
programming language and why hope you
enjoyed the video don't forget to like
this and share it with your friends and
subscribe to Simply learn to never miss
out on any updates thanks for watching
until next time stay safe and keep
learning
foreign